Dann geben wir es Kira und Michael und die machen dann was damit. Das ist eine Möglichkeit. Wir geben es vielleicht an die OK Labs, also an Open Knowledge Labs, die es in ganz Deutschland gibt, damit die Visualisierung bauen damit zum Beispiel. Also irgendwie diese Datensätze erfahrbar machen. Idealerweise schauen, ja okay, wenn wir das jetzt in Berlin haben, wenn wir jetzt die Daten über die Wasserqualität des Leitungswassers in Berlin haben und jetzt diese Anwendungen haben, wo man das schnell checken kann für sich. Ja, wenn wir es in Berlin haben, dann wollen wir es in Köln aber auch. Und dann wollen wir es aber auch in Heilbronn und so weiter. Und dann kann man es da redeployen. Das ist dann so der nächste Weg, aber der ist dann nicht unbedingt man noch bei den Daten befreiern.
Ja, okay, also wenn man diese überstrapazierte Metapher von Daten als Öl benutzt, seid ihr quasi die Förderer und danach geht es in die Raffinerie.
Ich würde gerne diese Metapher anzünden.
Passt ja auch, ist ja Öl. Kira, was macht ihr jetzt mit den Daten?
Eine ganze Menge, Journalismus machen wir mit den Daten.
Ja, aber wie sieht das aus? Also ich meine, da hat man halt diesen Datenberg, der ist auch irgendwie zugänglich. Dann gibt es ja zwei Fragen. Die eine ist, wie ziehe ich daraus eine Erkenntnis? Also rühr ich die so lange um, bis da irgendwer rausfällt? Und wenn ja, was ist in dieser Metapher der Kochtopf und der Löffel? Und dann, wie präsentiert man es so, dass es auch Leute versteht, die keine Datenjournalisten sind?
Okay, also unsere Ziel ist ja immer eine Geschichte mit den Daten zu erzählen. Das heißt, im Idealfall haben wir jetzt einen wunderbaren Datensatz gefunden, der irgendwie, wo wir was Interessantes drin sehen, was irgendwie eine journalistische Geschichte werden kann. Dann müssen wir die Daten irgendwie erst mal sauber machen, weil im Zweifelsfall sind sie in irgendeinem PDF. Müssen wir erst mal in schöne Tabellenform bringen, sodass wir sie weiterverarbeiten können. Müssen sie dann vielleicht analysieren, mal gucken, was ist irgendwie der größte Wert, was ist der kleinste Wert, wo ist der jüngste Kiez in Berlin. Das kann sich natürlich währenddessen einfach nochmal verändern. Wir müssen ja auch, ich meine, die Geschichte kann ja nicht ohne die Daten geschehen. Wir gehen mit einer Idee ran, was da drin sein kann. Und in der Recherche, in der Datenanalyse kommen dann bestimmte Aspekte raus, die wir besonders interessant finden, wie zum Beispiel, ich hatte ja zum Anfang schon mal von diesem Projekt erzählt, woher die Düsseldorfer kommen. Und da ist mir nämlich zum Beispiel erst dann aufgefallen, dass diese kleinen Gemeinden in Marokko so spannend sind, nachdem ich die Daten schon längst hatte, schon längst in hübsche Form gebracht habe für mich selber, für die Analyse. Und dann mal geguckt habe, welcher Prozentsatz der Bevölkerung von diesem kleinen Ort ist denn jetzt nach Düsseldorf gezogen und habe festgestellt, oh, das ist irgendwie ein ziemlich großer Teil in drei verschiedenen Dörfern. Was machen die denn alle in Düsseldorf? Das ist eine Geschichte. Und dann ist die Frage, wie bereiten wir das auf? Weil letzten Endes ist es tatsächlich so, dass ich es vielleicht mag, auf Excel-Tabellen zu starren, aber unsere Leser, Hörerinnen und Hörern, außer mir, dann halt niemand, genau. Deswegen wollen wir das unserem Publikum natürlich auch nicht antun. Und das kann, also Datenschule, und das läuft häufig online. Einfach weil wir da viele lustige Möglichkeiten haben, daraus bunte Grafiken zu machen, eine hübsche Karte zu machen. Balken-Diagramme sind vielleicht nicht das schönste Beispiel, aber schöne bunte Grafiken, wo man auf einen Blick sehen kann, aha, hier, das ist die Geschichte. Dieser Balken ist viel länger als einer anderen. Oh, das ist spannend im Idealfall. Es kann aber auch heißen, ich mache daraus ein Radiostück. Also ich habe eine Hintergrundrecherche gemacht und die sagt mir jetzt, aha, dieser Teil von Düsseldorf wäre jetzt total spannend mal zu besuchen. Und dann geht der Reporter los und stellt sich dahin und sagt, hier, ich stehe jetzt an der so und so Straße, hier leben so und so viele Marokkaner, ungewöhnlich viele. Wir gehen in dieses Café, hier lebt die Familie sowieso und macht daraus eine klassische journalistische Reportage. So kann es auch passieren.
Jetzt gibt es ja aber, also durchs Netz geht es nicht. Was will man, eine interessante Datenrecherche? Also ich habe das Gefühl, es gibt so in semi-regelmäßigen Abständen, kommt meistens sind es so Zeitungsportale um die Ecke mit. Wir haben mal hier eine schöne Visualisierung für was auch immer. Was ich mich frage ist, was kann die klassischjournalistischen Inhalte machen, die über die klassischen Verbreitungswege gehen? Dann hängt es natürlich auch davon ab, wie hoch ist der Erkenntnis aus den Daten geworden? Wie gut ist die Geschichte auch journalistisch handwerklich gemacht? Bei diesen Daten, habt ihr da Einblicke, werden diese Visualisierungen wirklich genutzt? Oder ist das eher so, guck mal, das ist bunt, das kann man gut retweeten, aber eigentlich guckt sich ja jetzt keiner die Sachen genau an.
Also man muss ehrlich sagen, gegen Dschungelcamp kommt Datenjournalismus nicht an.
Wahrscheinlich auch als Chaosradio, auch wenn sie traurige Wahrheit ist von der Quoten her.
Genau, also dagegen kommen wir letzten Endes nicht an, aber das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht das Ziel so richtig. Und ansonsten muss man sagen, das wird tatsächlich durchaus genutzt, einfach weil es macht vielleicht dem Publikum auch tatsächlich Spaß, nicht irgendwie eine Wand an Text zu lesen, sondern irgendwie zwischendurch mal zu verschnaufen und sich was Buntes anzugucken. Was auch immer wirklich wirklich gut läuft, ist was, wo ich meine eigene Adresse eingeben kann. Da steht eine größere Geschichte hinter. Ich kann mir irgendwie die ganze Welt angucken, aber zu der ganzen Welt habe ich vielleicht nicht so einen Bezug wie zu der Straße, wo ich wohne, das kenne ich. Da sehe ich die lustigen Häuser und ich sehe dann, ah okay, hier kommen also auch 50 Leute her, die jetzt in Düsseldorf leben, abgefahren.
Also ich muss ja, ich habe neulich in so einer Ausstellung, wo es um Geheimdienste und Sicherheit ging, gesehen, hier in diesem, können sie ihr Passwort eingeben, wir checken, wir sichern das. Und es ist dasselbe und ich persönlich habe dasselbe Gefühl, auch immer wenn irgendwo steht, gib mal deine Adresse. Ich so, nice try, aber nein. Vielleicht dürft ihr wissen, wo meine Großmutter wohnt oder so, aber da haben Leute tatsächlich Interesse dran.
Ja, also ich möchte dir jetzt nichts unterstellen, aber vielleicht bist du auch ein bisschen paranoider als der Durchschnittsmensch. Das kann überhaupt gar nicht sein.
Was habt ihr aus mir gemacht?
Also ich verspreche auch, wir nutzen die Daten nicht um, sie an irgendwelche Werbefirmen weiter zu verkaufen. Ganz subtil sind wir noch nicht gesunken. Wir werden sehen. Ich hoffe, weder noch. Ich glaube, das wird nicht so passieren. Nein, natürlich nicht. Also Nutzerdaten zu speichern ist natürlich was, da muss man transparent mit sein und sonst was. Es kann natürlich auch was Schönes sein, dass man sagt, ich vergleiche mich jetzt mit den anderen Lesern. Zum Beispiel gibt es immer wieder Geschichten, zeichne selber mal die deutsche Teilung ein, zeichne selber mal die Berliner Mauer ein. Und wir stellen fest, du bist schlechter als 80% der anderen Leser. Du hast also keine Ahnung, du kommst aus dem Rheinland, Kira, bitte, ehrlich, geh. Da ist dann vielleicht was, wo es auch ganz nett ist, sich mit anderen Nutzer zu vergleichen. Aber ansonsten machen wir das natürlich nicht. Und tatsächlich, das machen Leute, ihre eigene Adresse eingeben. Das kommt gut.
Aber das heißt, also Datenjournalismus ist tatsächlich an der Stelle auch ein Werkzeug, wo sich Nutzerinnen und Nutzer in Beziehungen mit der Geschichte setzen können. Weil ansonsten kann man ja immer nur gucken, also, die Protagonistinnen und Protagonistinnen gleichen die mir jetzt, kann ich Sympathie einfach nachfüllen. Aber da ist es eher ein Ansatz, wo man Menschen reinziehen kann auch.
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Möglichkeit und ich finde auch eine sehr wertvolle Möglichkeit von Datenjournalismus. Zumindest, wenn es eben diese interaktive Darstellungsform wird. Ich meine, das ist ja die Idee hinter Interaktivität. Ich kann damit in Beziehung treten und kann eben ein bisschen meine eigene Geschichte darin finden, tatsächlich. Wenn ich irgendwie einen Text lese, dann liest jeder den gleichen Text. Wenn ich aber eine interaktive Visualisierung habe, wo ich selber drin rumsuchen kann, dann suche ich mir auch so ein bisschen meine eigene Geschichte. Muss man natürlich vorsichtig mit umgehen, weil die Leute wollen auch nicht eine halbe Stunde lang auf fünf verschiedenen Ebenen rumklicken können. Also Buttons immer sehr sparsam einsetzen, aber prinzipiell klar gibt es den Leuten die Möglichkeit, ihre eigene Geschichte zu suchen.
Was machst du eigentlich mit den Daten?
Also ich würde noch ein bisschen was ergänzen zu, wenn man halt viel mit solchen Datenprojekten arbeitet. Ich greife jetzt mal das Beispiel der Bundestagswahl raus, wo wir beim Tagesspiegel einen extra Wahlportal gemacht haben, um die Wahlergebnisse darzustellen. Die meisten Daten, die wir benutzt haben, sind eigentlich gar nicht sichtbar. Die haben wir im Hintergrund gebraucht, um Daten umzurechnen, um sie in einer Karte darzustellen. Wir haben OpenStreetMap-Daten genutzt, um zu gucken, wo leben überhaupt Leute, damit wir nicht das Tempelhofer Feld einmalen, wie viele SPD-Wähler es dort gibt oder so. Also ganz viele Daten benutzen wir im Hintergrund und sind eigentlich gar nicht sichtbar vorne. Das ist so ein bisschen der Vor- und Nachteil von Open Data. Ich würde, Open Data ist eigentlich so eine Art Datengrundversorgung, die man braucht. Also es bringt mir ja nichts, irgendwie die Adressen von, was ist ich, Berliner Schulen zu wissen, wenn ich nicht mal nachschlagen kann, was ist denn die Geokoordinate dieser Schule an? Also brauche ich irgendwie eine Datenbank, um zu gucken, wo sind denn diese Adressen in Berlin genau? Und der Nachteil für Open Data entsteht dadurch, dass viele Open Data-Nutzungen gar nicht sichtbar sind. Das heißt, die Daten werden intensivst genutzt, aber derjenige, der die erstellt hat, sieht gar nicht, wo. Wo die tatsächlich eingesetzt werden. Ein schönes Beispiel, hatte ich letztens in einem Podcast Raumzeit gehört, da geht es um das Copernicus-Projekt. Das ist ein Satellitensystem der ESA, die im Prinzip die Erde umkreisen, und sie konnte nicht einscannen. So kann man das vielleicht formulieren. Und die haben vorher diese Daten versucht zu verkaufen, haben versucht, ein Geschäftsmodell zu machen. Und haben dann nach Jahrzehnten festgestellt, wir kriegen nur 0, 1% der Kosten rein, weil so ein Satellitensystem ist ja teuer, und so viel zahlen die Unternehmen halt auch nicht dafür. Und die haben jetzt diese Daten komplett als Open Data ins Identität gepackt unter sahihub.com.au, ich glaube EU oder sowas. Da kann man reinzoomen, kann sich alles Kartenmaterial angucken. Die haben seitdem, die Nutzerzahlen explodieren, sind jetzt bei 100.000 und so weiter. Und wo die eingesetzt werden, da sehen die gar nicht, ob das irgendwelche Start-up sind, ob das irgendwelche Konzerne sind, Verwaltungen, die da drinnen nachschlagen, das weiß man halt nicht. Und das ist so ein bisschen der Nachteil, dass ich die Wirkung von Open Data nicht nachprüfen kann, weil ich nicht sehe, wo es tatsächlich eingesetzt wird. Ich würde es tatsächlich als eine Grundversorgung der Gesellschaft mit Daten bezeichnen.
Aber das heißt, bei dir selber ist dann auch die Arbeit beendet, wenn du es irgendwie veröffentlichst? Also wenn du den Datensatz veröffentlichst? Oder wie sieht dein Prozess aus, wie du aus den Daten dann noch was machst? Und wie präsentierst du das?
Na also ich hatte ja auch lange Zeit als Datenjournalist gearbeitet, deswegen war da mein Prozess ganz ähnlich wie bei Kira. Dass wir die Daten genommen haben, dann oft mit anderen Daten kombiniert haben, versucht in irgendeiner ansprechenden Form zu veröffentlichen. Manchmal waren es tatsächlich Geschichten, die wir miterzählt haben. Manchmal waren es interaktive Werkzeuge, mit denen die Leute rumspielen konnten. Ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an das Projekt 1928.tagespiele.de. Das ist nichts weiter als eine Art Google Maps. Wenn ich dadurch Berlin laufe, kann ich mir sozusagen angucken, wie sieht Berlin aus. Aber die Karte ist zweigeteilt. Links ist es 1928, rechts ist es heute. Da sieht man ganz gut, welche Gebäude noch stehen, wie die Siegessäule verschoben wurde. Wie sah der Görlitzer Park eigentlich aus? Da soll ja mal ein Bahnhof gewesen sein. Vor dem Tagesspiegel steht so eine alte Mauer. Die habe ich nie bemerkt, bis ich irgendwann verstanden habe. Stimmt, der Anhalter Bahnhof stand ja da mal. Du hast die nie bemerkt? Ich bin da durchgelaufen und habe die nicht bemerkt. Ich bin Nerd, ich gucke mein Telefon.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, öfter mal vom Smartphone hochgucken. Komm doch mal in die Real World.
Das Tolle ist, das Smartphone hat mir jetzt gezeigt, dass da diese Mauer ist.
Ich sage jetzt, vielleicht hatte Spitzer doch recht. Okay, was ich noch fragen wollte ist, wenn der die Daten zur Verfügung stellt und selber auch schon drauf rumgedacht und rumgearbeitet hat, ist es euch schon passiert, dass dann erst durch die Interaktivität, die auch mit drin war, dass dann noch mal Dinge rausgekommen sind von Nutzerinnen und Nutzern, wo ihr dachtet so, wow, krass, das habe ich gar nicht bemerkt. Oder habt ihr so einen Nachfolgeffekt noch mal gesehen?
Beim Zugmonitor war das so, dass wir diese Daten aus der Deutschen Bahn rausgescrapt haben, sie live als Karte dargestellt haben und Wert darauf gelegt haben, dass die Daten, die wir rausgescrapt haben, noch mal irgendwo zum Runterladen anbieten. Die rechtliche Situation, unter welcher Lizenz man sie hätte veröffentlichen dürfen, war nicht ganz geklärt, aber zumindest haben wir es getan. Da gab es viele Nachfolgeprojekte daraus, z.B. Leute, die die Sinnhaftigkeit von Stuttgart 21 nachgerechnet haben, zu gucken, wie viel Verkehr tatsächlich durchging. Es gab noch zwei weitere Projekte, an die ich mich nicht erinnern kann. Aber das finde ich ganz gut, wenn man die Methoden und Daten für die journalistischen Projekte noch mal veröffentlicht. Da gibt es Folgesachen, die manchmal auch ganz hübsch sind und sinnvoll.
Mir ist es bisher noch nicht so passiert, dass jemand gesagt hat, ich habe eure Karte angeguckt und mir ist dieser eine Ort speziell aufgefallen. Würde ich mich aber total drüber freuen. Also sollte hier irgendwer zuhören. Das nächste Datenprojekt, was ihr seht, schreibt gerne den Autoren, wenn ihr irgendwas Spannendes seht. Die freuen sich, glaube ich, immer. Was ich aber schon hatte, ist, dass tatsächlich auch hinterher Wissenschaftler gekommen sind, der Redaktion geschrieben haben und gesagt haben, so etwas ganz Ähnliches wollte ich auch mal machen, habe ich auch schon mal gemacht. Könnt ihr da nochmal die Methodik erklären? Könnt ihr da nochmal irgendwie vielleicht Zugang zu den Daten geben? Und sowas freut uns natürlich immer. Schön wäre es natürlich, wenn man sich dann vorher vielleicht sogar trifft und sich sogar austauschen kann. Aber wenn man sich da gegenseitig dadurch weiterhelfen kann, ist das super.
Wir hatten übrigens, wenn mir noch ein, bei der Tegel-Befragung, die parallel zur Bundestagswahl lief, hatten wir die grafisch dargestellt und hatten ein Wahlbüro gefunden, das offensichtlich falsche Ergebnisse ausgeworfen hat und konnten das wieder zurückspielen an die statistischen Ämter, um die Wahl ohne nochmal zu prüfen.
Aber das heißt sozusagen, in dem, wie ihr das macht, ist das schon eher eine Präsentation. Also ja, man kann da irgendwie drin rumklicken und so, das ist auch nice, aber das ist erstmal ein Aussenden, diese Information auf eine andere Art und Weise, wie wir es gewohnt sind, aber von one way, mehr oder weniger.
In vielen Fällen schon. Also es ist natürlich, es ist einfach eine journalistische Sache. Es ist häufig im Journalismus so, dass es auch immer noch viel so gedacht wird. Okay, wir produzieren unsere Inhalte, wir präsentieren die so und das war's. Aber, und darüber freue ich mich auch, dass es auch immer mehr Initiativen gibt, zu versuchen, ein bisschen in Interaktion mit dem Publikum zu treten. Das ist aber nichts, was jetzt, also in meiner Erfahrung nicht so spezifisch für den Datenjournalismus ist, sondern einfach generell es Initiativen im Journalismus gibt, zu sagen, komm, wir treten mal in Dialog. Was interessiert unsere Leser eigentlich wirklich? Wie ist diese Geschichte angekommen? Wie können wir Feedback vom Publikum zu einer Geschichte irgendwie vielleicht nochmal einarbeiten?
Ich will jetzt gerne noch zwei Probleme beleuchten oder Dinge, wo ich mich frage, ob das Probleme sein können. Das eine ist, oder es hat beides damit zu tun, dass ihr ja nicht nur sozusagen eine Datenquelle nehmt und dann sozusagen die verarbeitet, sondern auch Daten miteinander kombiniert und auch daraus Dinge versteht. Das eine ist ja, es gibt ja dieses Schöne, dass man Korrelationen mit Kausalität nicht verwechseln sollen, also nur weil, keine Ahnung, die Kurve der Pflaumenernte und die Kurve der Meteoriteneinschläge gleichzeitig nach oben geht. Das bedeutet nicht zwangsweise, dass Pflaumen Meteoriten sind. Wie schützt man sich vor sowas?
Passiert das? Das ist ja das, was ich vorhin auch meinte. Man ist als Journalist vielleicht schon, aber meistens kein ausgewöhneter Statistiker zum Beispiel. Das heißt, sowas passiert definitiv. Und da ist es, finde ich, wichtig, dass gerade jeder, der datenjournalistisch arbeitet, mein wegen aber auch gerne wirklich jeder, der journalistisch arbeitet, ein bisschen genug Grundwissen in Statistik hat, um zu wissen, was komplex ist. Also einfach, um zu wissen, okay, hier, ich habe doch mal das gehört mit Korrelation und Kausalität. Wenn ich mir nicht sicher bin, dann frage ich vielleicht noch mal nach bei einem Wissenschaftler vom Fach oder bei einem Statistiker.
Das fällt mir relativ oft im Journalismus auf. Und das finde ich ganz gut, dass es jetzt mehr Datenjournalisten in Redaktionen gibt, die dieses Wissen auch einfach weitergeben, dass eine Korrelation nicht ausmarsch-kausalität ist.
Ja, aber die Frage geht schon ein bisschen weiter. Ihr denkt, ihr macht aber was mit den Daten. Kann man immer sichergehen, der Schluss, den ich jetzt daraus ziehe, ist auch wirklich der richtige?
Also komplett sichergehen kann man natürlich nicht. Man kann mit ein bisschen Common Sense auf jeden Fall dran gehen. Und es gibt im Journalismus einfach auch ein bisschen Qualitätssicherungsmethoden, die wir auf jeden Fall anwenden müssen. Also dann schauen wir halt irgendwie so ein bisschen, wir gucken uns Stichproben aus den Daten an und schauen, ist das plausibel, gerade wenn man zum Beispiel geografische Daten hat auf Berlin-Ebene, ist das schon passiert, dass ich die Daten irgendwie mal auf eine Karte geworfen habe und eine Kollegin, die daneben stand, sagt im Moment, nee in Schöneberg, da wohne ich aber. Das weiß ich aber ganz sicher, dass der Punkt da nicht hingehört. Sowas hilft auch einfach wirklich mehrere Augen drüber gucken zu lassen. Häufig ist man einfach so in seinem Arbeitsablauf drin, dass man manche Fehler gar nicht bemerkt.
Ich habe dafür einen Test, der lässt sich auch ganz leicht merken. Den nenne ich einfach jetzt mal ABBACAB-Test. Der Trick besteht darin, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie zwei Sachen habe, A und B, und ich will jetzt wissen, es gibt irgendwie eine Korrelation dazwischen. Wie ich wissen, gibt es dann auch eine Kausalität dahinter. Und dann kann man sagen, wenn es irgendwo eine Korrelation zwischen zwei Sachen gibt, gibt es immer drei Möglichkeiten, wie die Kausalität entstehen kann. Aus A folgt B, aus B folgt A, oder es gibt ein unbekanntes C, aus dem A und B folgt. Wenn ich das jetzt mal durchgehe, schnell durchlaufe, verheiratete Menschen leben länger, dann heißt das, wenn Leute verheiratet sind, leben sie länger. Kann gut sein, weil ich kümmere mich lieber um meine Familie, statt mit einem schnellen Motorrad zu fahren. Ich kann auch gucken, geht es andersherum, wer länger lebt, ist verheiratet. Stimmt, wer zum Beispiel mit 17 bei einem Motorradunfall ums Leben kommt, hat da nicht mehr die Chance zu heiraten. Oder die dritte Variante, es gibt was Unbekanntes, aus dem A und B folgt, beispielsweise, ich habe eine schwere Krankheit, ich habe Krebs oder so was. Das sorgt dafür, dass ich zum einen Schwierigkeiten habe, vielleicht einen Lebenspartner zu finden und zum anderen lange zu leben. Und wenn man das bei einer Korrelation einfach sich durchgeht, diese drei Varianten kann man halt gucken, ob man vielleicht auch noch auf andere mögliche Ursachen stößt und ob diese Korrelation wirklich aussagefähig ist oder nicht.
Wie oft ist es auch passiert, dass ihr in der Geschichte, es gibt diesen Begriff Tod recherchiert habt, also dass man, man hat eine These, man geht hin, zieht die Daten und denkt so, ja, nee, das war es nicht.
Passiert, also passiert auch, passiert immer mal wieder. Also wo ich mich auch ein bisschen geärgert hat, weil ich wirklich dachte, das wäre eine gute Geschichte. Ich war letztes Jahr bei der Times in London mal zum Praktikum. Und das hatte ich mir noch mal genau angeschaut. Ich hatte mir angeguckt, Spenden von Pharmaunternehmen an Ärzte. Das ist auf EU-Ebene, glaube ich, eine Datenbank. Und welche Medikamente diese Ärzte verschreiben. Da gibt es nämlich großartige, offene Daten vom NHS, vom National Health Service, also dem Gesundheitssystem in der UK. Und ich war mir so sicher, es muss doch irgendwie drin zu sehen sein, wenn dieser Arzt super viel Geld von irgendeinem Pharmaunternehmen bekommen hat. Dann verschreibt er doch bestimmt mehr Medikamente von diesem Pharmaunternehmen. Und ich habe zwei Tage daran rumgeschrieben. Ich habe es aus allen Winkeln betrachtet. Ich wollte wirklich, dass da irgendwas ist, aber da war nicht mal eine Korrelation da, die man mit Kausalität verwechseln könnte. Ich habe mich so geärgert. Passiert.
Ja, ist das ein Problem? Spätestens, wenn man das für Geld macht, dann verwendet man ja Arbeitszeit, um herauszufinden, dass es doch nicht so ist.
Also ich hatte da das zweifelhafte Glück, gar nicht bezahlt zu werden. Ich war Praktikantin, da wird man nicht bezahlt. Das ist eine Ehre. Nein, es ist natürlich irgendwie ein Problem. Ich glaube, es ist weniger ein Problem, wenn du fest in der Redaktion arbeitest oder zumindest fest die Zeit sowieso eingeplant hast. Es ist vielleicht tatsächlich mehr ein Problem, wenn du als freier Journalist Geschichten recherchierst, die du dann Medien anbieten möchtest. Weil dann hast du da irgendwie drei Tage Arbeit reingesteckt, wirst aber gar nicht bezahlt, weil keine Geschichte da ist.
Aber das ist sozusagen, wie bei vielen Sachen, anscheinend dann auch so, dass es theoretisch eigentlich besser ist. Redaktionen würden sich Datenjournalisten halten.
Nein, ist das Wort.
Also sagen, würden Menschen dafür bezahlen, einen totalen Datenjournalismus zu betreiben, und zwar unabhängig davon, ob dann das Story rausfällt oder nicht?
Also ich bin total dafür, uns zu bezahlen.
Ich meine, es gibt immer dieses Freelancer vs. Fest. Und als fester Redakteur oder fester Journalist oder Journalistin kannst du sie halt eher leisten zu sagen, ne, die Geschichte gibt einfach nichts her, lass uns das nicht machen. Und dann verdienst du trotzdem Geld. Und als Freelancer oder Freelancerin ist ja das Problem einfach, wenn du sagst, ich habe recherchiert dieses Thema, was wir zusammen geplant haben, aber das ist halt einfach nix, dann kriegst du halt auch nix.
Ja, das ist glaube ich kein spezifisches Datenjournalistisches Problem. Also auch Freijournalisten, die andere Geschichten recherchieren, denen kann es passieren, dass es platt ist.
Das ist schon klar, aber ich frage mich sozusagen, wenn man in den Daten drin ist, ob dann die Versuchung vielleicht höher ist, zu sagen, ja da kann ich aber, wenn ich die Kurve da so hinschiebe, dann sieht das schon extrem krass aus.
Also das muss man sagen, also die Versuchung ist da. Ich hoffe von mir behaupten zu können, dass ich dem nicht nachgebe. Die Versuchung ist definitiv da und ich denke, dass die bestimmt größer ist, wenn man einfach ökonomischen Druck dahinter hat. Selbst ohne ist es häufig so. Ich hatte auch schon eine ähnliche Geschichte, und der Redakteur wirklich drei Tage hintereinander nachgefragt hat, bitte guckst du dir noch mal aus dem anderen Blick an, ich bin mir so sicher und ich nur erzählt habe, es ist nichts da. Es ist da einfach nichts.
Ich finde ja einfach als Zuschauer, als Leser auch Geschichten spannend, wo jemand schreibt, ich habe nachgeguckt und ich habe nichts gefunden. Und das wird viel zu wenig gemacht, finde ich, weil das trotzdem total spannende Geschichten sein können.
Ja, das muss ich richtig nehmen. Aber dich wollte ich jetzt hier auch noch fragen. Du hast ja am Anfang der Sendung gesagt, deine Motivation ist oft so ein, da stimmt was nicht. Und du hast auch erzählt, es ist nicht so einfach, an die Daten ranzukommen. Und da könnte ich mir auch vorstellen, dass man auch sozusagen in so eine Falle laufen kann, dass man denkt, man hat dieses ganz starke Gefühl und es ist schwer, an die Daten ranzukommen. Jetzt hat man vielleicht ein Datum, was sagt, haha, ich habe recht. Woher weißt du denn, dass du genug hast? Also woher weißt du denn, dass du wirklich alles, was verfügbar ist, da hast?
Ich habe nie genug.
Ok, verstehe. Also Datenaktivist ist ein Merkmal, was man unbedingt haben muss. Nie genug Daten haben. Die andere Sache, die ich euch noch fragen wollte, ist, wenn wir über soziale Netzwerke reden und über Ad-Tracking im Netz, also wo wir irgendwie alle verfolgt werden, da ist ja die Warnung, die wir machen, oder die halt immer gesagt wird, ist, naja, da werden halt Daten miteinander kombiniert, die echt krasse Aussagen zulassen, die du vielleicht eigentlich gar nicht willst. Du willst gar nicht, dass dich eine Firma oder ein Werbetracker so genau kennt, wie die das können, weil die verschiedene Datenquellen kombinieren. Natürlich hellhörig, weil ein großer Teil eurer Arbeit ist es, Datenquellen zu kombinieren. Ist es eine Gefahr, dass da Dinge passieren können, dass ihr Daten miteinander kombiniert und an die Öffentlichkeit geben, die dann Effekte haben, die nicht wünschenswert sind? Ich versuche mir ein Beispiel auszudenken. Was erzählt das? Düsseldorf, wo kommen die Leute her? Dass man da was über einzelne Menschen herausfinden kann oder Dinge herausfinden kann, die vielleicht gefährlich sind?
Das Beispiel ist dafür gar nicht so schlecht. Prinzipiell kann das natürlich passieren. Da muss man vorsichtig sein. Aber da gibt es in Deutschland keinen schlechten Datenschutz, wie das hinter den Kulissen aussieht. Aber die Daten, die in die Öffentlichkeit kommen, die sind in den allermeisten Fällen genügend anonymisiert. Beispielsweise bei der Geschichte, woher die Düsseldorfer kommen, hatten wir nur Orte, aus denen mindestens 100 Menschen kommen. Bei 100 Menschen ist es extrem schwer, herauszufinden, das ist doch der Kevin von nebenan aus Marokko, den kenne ich doch. Das ist da nicht so das Problem. In kleineren Kommunen, die sowieso nur 5.000 Einwohner haben, passiert es schneller mal, dass die Daten auch auf sehr niedrigschwelligem Niveau verfügbar sind. Dann ist halt einfach die journalistische Ethik gefragt. Wie anonymisieren wir die Daten so, dass man das eben nicht machen kann. Das ist dann nicht das Ziel der Sache, der Sinn der Sache.
Arne, habt ihr schon mal irgendwie Daten nie genug Daten bekommen und die natürlich auch an alle weitergehen, wo ihr nachher so gedacht habt, naja, vielleicht war das möglicherweise doch keine so gute Idee.
Nicht direkt so, aber natürlich sind Datenschutzprobleme immer mal wieder da. Aber aus einem anderen Grund vor allem, in der Zusammenarbeit oder wie auch immer gegen die Behörden, wenn es Datenschutzprobleme gibt, wenn also mehr personenbezogene Daten an die Öffentlichkeit kommen als sie sollten, dann ist das meiner Erfahrung nach in der Regel der Fall, weil die Medienkompetenz der zuständigen Behördenmitarbeiter nicht hoch genug ist. Heißt, eine Excel-Datei und dann wird statt eine Spalte zu löschen, die Spalte verborgen und sie ist immer noch drin. Solche Sachen sind eher Grund dafür, dass gerade so in diesem Open Data Bereich Daten an die Öffentlichkeit kommen, die es nicht sollten, als dass da jetzt irgendwie absichtlich zu viel veröffentlicht wird.
Sind Metadaten ein Problem? Also es gibt gerade Excel-Tabellen zum Beispiel enthalten, nicht nur das, was man sieht, wenn man es aufmacht. Da drin stecken immer noch so Sachen, wie welches Betriebssystem, wie heißt der User und so weiter und so fort. Gibt es da Dinge?
Ist eh meistens Windows 7.
Aber führt ihr da eine Bereinigung durch, wenn ihr die Daten aufarbeitet?
Nee, das ist in der Regel dann, wenn es um Behörden geht, die Aufgabe der Behörde.
Das klingt nach einem interessanten datenschulistischen Projekt, oder? Alle PDFs von Kleine Anfragen.de Kommt raus überall Windows 7.
Na gut, wir machen jetzt noch eine kleine Pause. Es gibt noch eine Runde Nerd News und danach geben wir die letzte Runde. Da würde ich von euch mal gerne wissen wollen, was denn so die nächsten Projekte sind. Aber wie gesagt, erstmal eine kleine Runde Nerd News.
Der Internet-Pionier John Perry Barlow ist an Herzversagen gestorben. Barlow schrieb Songs für die Band Grateful Dead und setzte sich für Meinungsfreiheit und andere Bürgerrechte ein. Er verfasste 1996 die Unabhängigkeitserklärung des Cyberspace, die sich gegen die staatliche Kontrolle über das Internet wendet. Barlow ist vor allem als Gründer der Electronic Frontier Foundation und der Freedom of the Press Foundation bekannt. Die Whistle Blow, wie Edward Snowden und Chelsea Manning unterstützt und Schutzsoftware wie SecureDrop und Haven entwickelte. FitnessTracker verrät geheime Militärinformationen Eine Weltkarte des FitnessTrackers Strava enthielt seit 2015 vertrauliche militärische Nutzerdaten. Die Global Heatmap zeigte mehr als eine Milliarde Aktivitäten der Strava-Nutzer der letzten Jahre, die von ihnen selbst mit Trackern automatisch aufgezeichnet wurden. Weil zu den Nutzern offensichtlich viele Soldaten gehörten, konnte die Position geheimer Militärbasen aufgedeckt werden. Außerdem war es möglich, die Soldaten in ihre Heimat zurückzuverfolgen und zu deanonymisieren. Open Schufa will Scoring transparent machen. Das Crowdfunding-Projekt Open Schufa versucht herauszufinden, wie die Bonitätsauskunft bei Schufa ihr Scoring ermittelt. Der Score wird bei Ratenkäufen und anderen Vertragsabschlüssen zur Ermittlung der Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit von Zahlungen verwendet. Die Berechnungsmethode gilt als Betriebsgeheimnis und die Qualität der zugrundeliegenden Daten ist nicht bekannt. Open Schufa hofft, die Methoden und gegebenenfalls systemische Fehler der Scoringfirma offenlegen zu können und bittet dazu um Datenspenden von Schufa-Auskünften. Unterstützt wird Open Schufa von AlgorithmWatch, der Open Knowledge Foundation und Geldspenden.
New Retrowave von Data Fatale hier im Chaosradio 243, wo wir auf die Zielgerade der letzten halben Stunde einbiegen. Also ein bisschen radiosprechend muss auch mal sein. So, wir haben eine Zuschauer, Zuhörer oder Zuhörerinnen Frage, nämlich ist eine Fachfrage, bitte halten sie sich kurz oder verweisen sie auf Quellen. Was empfiehlt ihr für ein Framework, um Daten irgendwo rauszuziehen, Python-Request oder gibt es da grafische Tools, die einen das Leben vereinfachen? Könnt ihr, bevor ihr die Frage beantwortet, mir erklären, was die Frage bedeutet?
Ich müsste raten, aber ich würde raten, dass es um Scraping geht, Daten irgendwo rauszuziehen.
Also diese Webseiten danach untersuchen, was, wie man die Daten gibt. Gibt es eine Standardempfehlung? Gibt es einen Standardroboter, den man ins Web schicken kann?
Also, äh...
Gerüchteweise gibt es irgendwelche Browserplugins, die das auch können, aber ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht die Namen.
Da wirft man eine URL rein und dann zeigt die einem sozusagen an, was Datenpunkte sein könnten oder wie funktioniert das?
Bisschen komplexer als das, ja. Aber Webscraper ist zum Beispiel ein schön dokumentiertes Projekt, wo man schön reinkommt in Scraping. Also damit kann sogar ich Scrapen.
Also gut, du machst das jetzt professionell mit der Datensammlung. Gibt es so ein Ding für Leute, die anziehen? Also gibt es so etwas, was einem mal visualisiert, was so diese Struktur an der Webseite ist und wo man da Daten rausziehen könnte?
Also womit das relativ einfach geht, auch garantiert ohne Programmieren, ist import.io. Das hat kostenpflichtige Accounts, hat aber ein bisschen versteckt, aber man findet auch einen Studierenden, also einen Bildungsaccount auf jeden Fall. Der ist dann kostenlos und testen kann man es auch. Und das hat tatsächlich eine relativ einfache grafische Oberfläche. Und beim Scraping läuft das halt so, man muss sich ein bisschen die Struktur der Website durchgucken und schauen, an welchem Punkt der Struktur stehen die Daten drin, die ich haben will. Und import.io hilft einem dabei und visualisiert das ein bisschen schön grafisch und man kann irgendwie auf Dinge draufklicken, statt dass man Code schreiben muss.
Okay, das klingt ganz interessant und ist ja vielleicht auch ganz lehrreich, selbst wenn man kein Scraping macht, um mal ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, was eigentlich Webseite bedeutet. Ich würde jetzt gerne noch von euch wissen, was so das nächste Zukunftsprojekt ist. Wir hatten ja ein, zwei Mal schon den NerdNews genannt, wo die Open Schufa, da hängt der Herr Semsrott auch mit drin. Explainify.
Die Schufa ist ein wahnsinnig mächtiges Unternehmen, das wahnsinnig viele Daten hat. 813 Millionen Datensätze über 70 Millionen Bürger in Deutschland. Und damit eine enorme Macht über den Alltag von all diesen Menschen.
Ich tendiere im Chaosradio immer zu sagen, Schufa ist das Einzige, wo ich denke, das muss man nicht erklären. Weil die jeder hat schon mal damit zu tun gehabt, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich damit zu tun haben müssen dann sogar. Mindestens, wenn man einen Mietvertrag haben wollte. Aber der Algorithmus dahinter, also die Frage, wie kommt denn die Schufa eigentlich zu ihrem Score? Die ist ein Geschäftsgeheimnis. Und das wollen wir ein bisschen knacken. Wir wollen die Mechanismen hinter diesem Algorithmus freilegen. Und dazu suchen wir vor allem Datenspenden. Das heißt, die Idee hinter dem Schufa ist, dass alle Menschen ihre Schufa-Auskunft anfragen. Das ist dann in der Regel eine lange große Tabelle mit Prozentzahlen und ein paar Zeichen. Und dann diese Tabelle an uns spenden. Das heißt, einscannen über ein Tool, das wir noch entwickeln müssen. Und über diese Datenpunkte, die wir dann sammeln, also sagen wir mal, 10.000 Leute geben uns diese Tabelle, geben uns dann freiwillig dazu noch ein paar mehr Angaben über zum Beispiel Einkommensgruppe oder über Postgleitzahlgebiet, in dem sie wohnen. Und dann können wir mit all diesen Daten, die wir sammeln, Abhängigkeiten innerhalb dieser Werte finden. Das heißt, wir können idealerweise, wenn alles super läuft, die Frage beantworten, diskriminiert die Schufa. Macht es einen Unterschied, ob ich im Norden oder Süden der Stadt wohne? Macht es einen Unterschied, ob ich Mann bin oder Frau? Was sind die einzelnen Datenpunkte, die diesen Scoringwert von der Schufa beeinflussen?
Wenn man das verfolgt, dann klingt das so, ihr wollt die Schufa-Formel reverse-engineeren, also quasi dazu, die wirklich sozusagen hinkriegen. Ist das wirklich das Ziel, am Ende diese Formel habt? Oder geht es eher darum zu sagen, wir haben so bestimmte What-the-fuck-Moment-Verdachte und wir wollen einmal nachprüfen, ob das sich irgendwie zeigt?
Also, die exakte Formel, die werden wir sicher nicht schaffen, weil wir dazu noch viel, viel mehr Daten sammeln müssen. Das können wir nicht machen. Aber ich glaube, wir können auf jeden Fall in die Richtung gehen, dass wir so bestimmte Hypothesen testen, dass wir zumindest rausfinden, was besonders wichtige Datenpunkte sind. Und ich stelle mir das so vor, dass am Schluss vielleicht eine sehr simple Formel dabei rumkommt. Aber vor allem ein Portal, wo man eingeben kann, das ist das Einkommen und ich bin Mann oder Frau und da wohne ich. Und dann kriegt man so ungefähr einen Schuferscore raus. Und dann kann ich ein bisschen rumspielen. Jetzt bin ich nicht mehr Mann, sondern Frau. Was macht das mit dem Schuferscore und so weiter? Das wäre die Ideallösung dabei. Aber wir brauchen halt die Mithilfe von möglichst vielen Leuten, die ihre Daten an uns spenden. Und das ist so was ziemlich Neues. Das gab es, glaube ich, zumindest in Deutschland so noch nicht. Und wir probieren das mal aus und schauen, wie das klappt.
Gibt es das? Ihr habt ja auch gerade so ein Crowdfunding zu laufen. Das ist, um das Tool zu schreiben, um diese Daten dann einzulesen.
Genau, also wir müssen es möglichst einfach machen, diese Daten zu spenden. Das ist so das eine. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, wie man es danach darstellt und so. Und dafür sammeln wir insgesamt 50.000 Euro. Jetzt sind wir bei 29.221 Euro. Ich bin minütlich auf dieser Startnext-Seite. Und reloade die die ganze Zeit. Ja, und wir hoffen, dass wir da die volle Summe zusammenkriegen.
Nach allem, was ihr mir erzählt habt in der Sendung, vermute ich, dass Schufa-Mitarbeiter da auch reichhaltig spenden.
Vielleicht ja von der Schufa-Konkurrenz, ist nicht so klar.
Apropos Konkurrenz, da kommen wir gleich drauf. Was ich jetzt tatsächlich vorher noch fragen wollte, ist... Nee, genau das doch. Die Schufa hat ja sozusagen auch darauf geantwortet. Ein sehr langes Schreiben. Der Wirtschaftsstaat Deutschland ist in Gefahr, wenn man da irgendwie drankommt. Und es ist auch ganz gefährlich, euch die Daten zu geben. Ihr seid ja ganz schlimme Verbrecher auch. Steht da nicht drin. Habe ich jetzt frei zwischen den Zeilen lesen paraphrasiert. Da findet aber schon Angstmacherei auch statt. Was passieren kann, wenn man die Daten an unbefugte Dritte geht. Aber der eine interessante Punkt, der man als Frage stellen kann, ist, die Schufa ist zwar das, was wir alle kennen, aber bei Weitem nicht die einzige Scoring-Firma in Deutschland. Es gibt auch eine andere, die heißt Avato. Die wiederum gehört zu Bertelsmann. Bertelsmann wiederum gibt Geld an AlgorithmWatch.
Bertelsmann-Schiftung. Bertelsmann gehört zur Bertelsmann-Schiftung.
Okay, einen Schritt über mein Bad. Zum Glück sind die Daten alle da. Und AlgorithmWatch ist wiederum euer Partner bei OpenShufa. Und die Frage, die die Shufa dargestellt hat, ist so, naja, das ist aber schon komisch, dass sie nur auf uns zeigt und nicht auf die Konkurrenz, wo über OpenWege auch Geld kommt.
Ja, also erst mal muss ich sagen, diese Stellungnahme, die die Shufa abgegeben hat, die war eine Woche lang prominent auf der Startseite von der Shufa verlinkt. Das war super. Das war die beste Werbung, die wir so haben konnten für das Projekt. Danke an die PR-Abteilung an dieser Stelle. Und zwar ins Ja, stimmt, die Battlesman-Stiftung gibt Geld an Algorithm Watch, nicht für dieses Projekt, aber zur Grundfinanzierung von der Organisation. Aber das heißt überhaupt nicht, dass wir uns nicht mit Avato Info Score beschäftigen. Ganz im Gegenteil, die ganzen Auskunftsanfragen nach den eigenen Daten, die gehen jetzt gerade nicht nur an die Shufa, sondern die gehen über das Portal, das wir nutzen, auskunft.net, auch an Avato Info Score zum Beispiel. In den letzten Tagen haben ein paar Tausend Leute auch da ihre Auskunft angefragt. Und idealerweise können wir am Schluss das Tool, das wir für die Shufa benutzen, auch für andere Auskunft, Auskunftteilen benutzen. Das heißt, natürlich muss nicht nur die Shufa transparenter werden, sondern all diese Auskunftteilen.
Aber es heißt ja Open Shufa, nicht Open Scoring-Unternehmen.
Die Shufa ist der Marktführer, die haben die meisten Daten. Natürlich fangen wir mit denen an. Aber mit denen müssen wir ja nicht aufhören. Das Crowdfunding geht noch 21 Tage. Und dann wollen wir im Mai die Software fertig haben und dann bis Juni schon die ersten Daten ausgewertet haben.
Was, es gibt ja, also von Computerspielen und Crowdfunding geht das so, wenn ihr doppelt so viel spendet, dann dürft ihr möglicherweise auch einen weiblichen Charakter spielen. Habt ihr auch so Bonusziele oder ist das eher so, ihr macht bei 50.000 zu, weil das reicht dann?
Ja, okay, wahrscheinlich weiß ich zu wenig über das Crowdfunding. Bitte spendet.
Nein, ich meine, es gibt ja sozusagen, es gibt ja manche Kicks, also Crowdfunding-Unternehmen, sagen ja, also wenn wir brauchen so und so viel, aber wenn das und das mehr kommt, dann machen wir noch das und das. Habt ihr auch so was? Also wir brauchen eigentlich 50, aber wenn wir bis 75 kommen, dann bauen wir auch gleich die Erwartungsschiene oder irgendwie so.
Ja, ich habe das jetzt nicht gesagt, weil es nicht so clever ist. Das erste Fundingziel ist 30.000. Das heißt, da fehlen uns jetzt noch 800 Euro. Und danach müssen wir auf 50.000 kommen. Dass wir zum Beispiel noch externe Experten hinzuziehen können und bezahlen können. Also ein paar Statistiker, die Modelle bei Banken bauen.
Das haben wir heute gelernt, so gute Statistiker dabei zu haben.
Genau. Und dass wir das alles ein bisschen hübscher machen können und so.
Na gut, kann man ja machen. Sehr schön. Und dann ist im Sommer, können wir alle gucken, was unser Score ist. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt. Spendet Daten, spendet Geld, ist eine gute Sache. Wahrscheinlich.
Kira, dein nächstes Projekt? Wir waren eben schon kurz beim Thema Konkurrenz. Deswegen, also für Journalisten ist es immer ein bisschen schwierig, über nächste Projekte zu sprechen. Open Data. Ich wünschte auch, es wäre anders, wirklich. Aber ich kann definitiv eins nennen, was mir seit Jahren im Kopf rumschwört, weil das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird. Aber ich bin nicht bereit, die Hoffnung aufzugeben, mal das Thema Obdachlosigkeit aus Datenperspektive zu beleuchten. Auch übrigens finde ich ein Thema, wo man überhaupt mal erst mal den Staat dazu bringen könnte, Daten zu erheben und die dann zu veröffentlichen, weil da die Datenlage wirklich katastrophal ist. Ich komme aus NRW, das ist das einzige Land, was überhaupt eine Statistik darüber führt, obwohl es Studien gibt, die sagen, es wäre möglich, das zu erheben. Ich habe mir die Statistik in NRW schon länger mal angeguckt. Die Definitionen gehen leider völlig an der Realität vorbei. Ich saß dann im Büro der Stadt und da sagte mir der nette Mitarbeiter, wie Obdachlose, die gibt es hier nicht. Ich dachte mir, das kann aber irgendwie auch nicht so richtig sein. Aber ich habe die Hoffnung noch nicht aufgegeben, da mal ein bisschen nach Daten zu gucken und das Thema so ein bisschen aufzubereiten.
Aber was ist die Hoffnung dahinter? Möchtest du einfach, dass man das auch auf eine etwas greifbare Form visualisieren kann, die sozusagen nicht irgendwie das bedrückende Foto ist?
Ja, exakt das. Das Thema Obdachlosigkeit ist, finde ich, ein extrem komplexes und ein extrem emotionalisiertes und eins, wo kaum jemand wirklich einen objektiven Pack an dran hat. Niemand hat eine Ahnung, wie viele Obdachlose es wirklich gibt. Es gab letztens die Nachricht, das wären irgendwie über eine Million in Deutschland. Das sind sehr grobe Schätzungen letzten Endes, schwer zu schätzen. Es gibt wenig Vorstellungen davon, wie der Alltag von solchen Menschen überhaupt aussieht. Zumindest nicht, was über einzelne Porträts hinausgeht, die häufig eben sehr emotional sind, sehr auf irgendwie entweder, oh, der Mensch ist total inspirierend oder, oh, Gottseidank, geht es mir nicht so schlecht, hinauslaufen. Das würde ich gerne mal aus einer anderen Perspektive erzählen.
Wo du jetzt gerade gesagt hast, du willst über die Projekte, die möglicherweise Erfolg haben, nicht reden. Ich frage mich, ist das so, also gerade wenn es um Daten geht, die sind ja, also Objektivität ist immer so eine schwierige Sache, aber es gibt ja Daten und die liegen auf der Hand und dann liegen vielleicht auch Interpretationen auf der Hand. Ist dir schon mal passiert, dass du sozusagen so, fuck, die Idee hatte ich auch.
Ja, absolut, also das passiert auch einfach und ich glaube, das passiert Datenjournalisten sehr viel häufiger als auch Journalisten aus anderen Ressorts, weil wenn du aus dem tagesaktuellen Berichtest ja, okay, dann hat der Martin Schulz halt gerade nur mal was gesagt, das ist okay, da berichtet jetzt halt wirklich jeder drüber, ist auch in Ordnung, wenn die Leute über das Gleiche schreiben, aber Datenjournalismus hat häufig eben so auch ein bisschen längerfristige Themen, ein bisschen zeitlosere Themen und da passiert es, dass du am gleichen Thema lange arbeitest. Also eine Art von Beispiel wäre die Bundestagswahl, da haben wirklich alle Datenteams in Deutschland sich aufs gleiche Thema gestürzt, das war aber immerhin allen vorher klar, dass da das gleiche passieren würde. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel letztens, da hat Zeit Online eine sehr, sehr schöne Geschichte rausgebracht, die haben Straßennamen in Deutschland analysiert, haben sich zum Beispiel angeguckt, wie unterscheiden die sich in Ost- und Westdeutschland, in Nord- und Süddeutschland, nach wem benennen wir eigentlich unsere Straßen, wer sind die Leute, nach denen wir diese Ehre irgendwie zuteilassen wollen, viele verben jetzt hier drin, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein kompletter Satz war. Wirklich schönes Projekt, wirklich schön visualisiert und ich hätte mir den Hintern beißen können. Ich wollte dieses Projekt nämlich seit zwei Jahren machen, hab mich total geärgert, ich konnte auch wirklich nur ein paar Mal einen kurzen Blick drauf werfen, da musste ich sie dazu machen. Hab mich dann bei Freunden dann darüber beschwert und drei von denen meinten, ach ja, das wollten wir auch schon mal machen, ach ja, wir hatten schon mal mit der Recherche angefangen. Also ja, es gibt naheliegende Daten und ja, das ist einfach ärgerlich, wenn sowas passiert, nichts zu machen.
Verstehe. Michael, kannst du noch etwas zur Zukunft deines Datenwissenschaftsjournalismus sagen?
Natürlich nicht, ich hab genau das gleiche Problem. Das ist schwierig sozusagen schon vorher Ideen zu veröffentlichen, weil dann, es ist ja irgendwie doof, wenn man dann Zeit reinsteckt, sondern dann ist jemand eine Woche vorher das raushaut oder sowas, dann ist man ja halt nur Nummer zwei, ist irgendwie doof. Eine Sache, die mir schon länger vorschwebt, ist das Problem, Open Data da in Deutschland die Unternehmen und die Behörden davon zu überzeugen und bei diesem Raumzeit-Podcast, als es um Copernicus ging, fand ich sehr interessant, dass sie darüber gesprochen haben, dass eines der stärksten Motivationen war, dass die NASA bereits Open Data macht und deswegen die ESA sich da eine Scheibe von abgeschnitten hat. Ich finde das ganz interessant, mal den internationalen Open Data Stand sich anzuschauen, welche Apps gibt es da draus, welche Services gibt es da und zu vergleichen, warum es die in Deutschland nicht gibt und dann vielleicht auch mal den Finger zu zeigen, hier du Verkehrsunternehmen behinderst uns da dran, dass wir so eine Apps machen können oder diese Behörde oder Verwaltung und so weiter. Da wirklich mal eine systematische, wie heißt das, Inventur zu machen, wie da der aktuelle Zustand ist, denn der ist nicht so schön wie im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern.
Gibt es denn ganz konkret noch Datenquellen, wo ihr sagt, okay, da möchten wir jetzt unbedingt dran, also über die wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen haben?
Mir fiel gerade mit dem Vergleich mit anderen Ländern ein. In den USA war es zumindest unter Obama immer üblich, dass das Besucherregister des Weißen Hauses öffentlich einsehbar war. Und das war Open Data und das war so ganz selbstverständlich und dann hat Donald Trump gesagt, okay, also ich glaube, eins der ersten Sachen, die er gemacht hat, ist, dieses Besucherregister wieder abzuschaffen. Und dann war großer Aufschrei und auch hierzulande, ah, kann er noch nicht machen, der Trump, aber niemand hat gefragt, wie ist denn hier. Es gibt kein Besucherregister vom Bundeskanzleramt, das öffentlich einsehbar ist. Und ich glaube, das wäre ein sehr interessanter Datensatz zu schauen, wer da so vorbeikommt, wer da vielleicht mal eine Geburtstagsfeier im Kanzleramt feiert, ist ja durchaus schon mal vorgekommen, der Deutsche Bank. Chef hat das ja zu seinem 60. gemacht.
Ja, genau, also ich hätte ja gerade schon gesagt, ich hätte die obdachlose Statistik wirklich gerne, dafür muss sie aber erst mal erhoben werden und erst mal entwickelt werden. Also was ich, ich habe jetzt keinen spezifischen Datensatz, aber was ich wirklich, wirklich schön fände ist, wenn, wenn es halbwegs einheitliches Datenportal für lokale Daten gäbe. Also es gibt, ich bin unglaublich dankbar über die Regionalstatistik von, von den statistischen Ämtern des Bundes und der, und der Länder, aber ich glaube einzelne Städte haben, sitzen auf solchen Datenschätzen und die irgendwie mal einheitlich hochzuladen, einfach damit man zumindest ein Grundlevel hat an, dass hier sind die Gebäude, so alt sind die Gebäude, so und so viele Leute leben an dieser Straße, in dieser Ecke der Stadt. Das müssen keine abgefahrene Datensätze sein, aber so eine Grundversorgung wäre wirklich schön.
Arne, korrigier mich, kann das sein, dass die Postleitzahlgebiete in Deutschland gar kein Open Data sind, sondern dass sie der deutschen Post gehören und dass du da richtig viel Geld bezahlen musst, um zu wissen, wo die Postleitzahlgebiete in Deutschland anfangen zu enden?
Ohne es zu wissen, würde ich dir erstmal zustimmen, ja.
Das ist ein Trauerspiel.
Das ist der Default, ja.
Im Rahmen der Privatisierung sind das jetzt sozusagen Daten in privater Hand und man kann die als Karte kaufen.
Apropos Straßenverzeichnis, es gibt auch kein offizielles Straßenverzeichnis einheitlich für ganz Deutschland. Das musst du auch irgendwie von den Ländern, manchmal von den Kommunen, einzeln manchmal kaufen, manchmal kostenlos kriegen. Gibt es über OpenStreetMap allerdings?
Achso, das haben wir gar nicht angesprochen im ganzen Ding, aber Föderalismus ist natürlich ein riesen Thema. 16 unterschiedliche Bundesländer, 16 unterschiedliche Regelungen, wie sie mit ihren Daten umgehen.
Und dann 16 verschiedene Software, dass alles gar nicht miteinander zu verbinden ist, die Daten.
Dann gibt es hier im Bundesamt noch Städte, die alle auch andere Systeme haben.
Okay, aber wir sind jetzt am Ende der Sendung, damit sollten wir nicht enden.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das klingt alles sehr, so Obdachlosigkeit, Föderalismus, das ist fürchterlich.
Dann möchte ich gerne noch was Positives dazu sagen, wir Deutschen meckern immer gerne auf hohem Niveau und zwar egal, wie hoch das Niveau ist, klar im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern sind wir ganz sicher nicht an der Spitze, aber es gibt auch Länder, mit denen wir uns vergleichen könnten, da sind wir sehr, sehr viel besser. Es gibt Länder, in denen du nicht mal vertrauen kannst, wie viele Leute im Land leben. Sowas haben wir, wir können auch prinzipiell irgendwie unserem Bruttoinlandsprodukt halbwegs vertrauen, wenn wir wissen, wie es berechnet wird. Also da muss man schon sagen, wir haben schon eine Grundversorgung, die okay ist und vor allem, was mir Hoffnung gibt, ist, es wird besser. Also die Stadt, in der ich studiert habe, hat jetzt jemanden, der sich für offene Daten einsetzt und die machen jetzt genau das, was mich im Studium nämlich so aufgeregt hat, die befreien jetzt Daten. Finde ich super.
Ist da die Hoffnung sozusagen, dass das wegstirbt, das Personal, das...
So drastisch wollen wir ja nicht werden. Die werden alle reformiert, sie sehen das Licht.
Das ist schon spannend, weil das letztlich dazu führt, dass dieser Kampf zwischen Bevölkerung und den Behörden inzwischen sich ein bisschen verlagert hat in die Behörden selbst. Also es sind dann teilweise die Abteilungen, die miteinander jetzt streiten und die jüngeren Kollegen, die dafür sind, das offen zu legen und die älteren, die es nicht wollen. Und das ist ja schon mal ein Anfang.
Sehr gut. Freie Daten. Michael, ich würde dich noch mal kurz fragen, um noch mal auf diese Social-Bot-Nummer zurückzukommen. Und die Tatsache, dass das soziale Netzwerk unser Leben bestimmt und aber alle Daten, die wir daraus haben, eigentlich von denen zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Also es gibt diese API, aber alles, was daraus fällt, muss man denen quasi glauben. Gibt es, und also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es so ein, oder schwierig, vielleicht gar nicht die Motivation so hoch ist, aber gibt es Versuche, von außen diese Netzwerke so zu beobachten, dass man sagen kann, wir haben jetzt wirklich offene, vertrauenswürdige Daten, weil wir die selber gesammelt haben? Oder sind diese Dinge einfach zu groß dafür?
Na ja, also da müssen wir ein bisschen unterscheiden. Es gibt unterschiedliche soziale Netzwerke. Bei Twitter sieht es eigentlich ganz gut aus. Da kriegt man über die API im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, was ich auch über die normale Seite sehen kann. Ganz schlecht sieht es natürlich bei Facebook aus, weil denen klar ist, umso mehr Daten sie rausgehen, umso mehr können andere Leute mit ihnen konkurrieren im Prinzip. Denn das Geschäftsmodell von Facebook ist es, so viele Daten wie möglich zu sammeln. Und da sehe ich auch besonders die Schwierigkeit, dass extra oder besonders viele Leute bei Facebook sind, das heißt, wenn diese sozialen Netzwerke, durch was auch immer, für Effekte, irgendwie einen Einfluss auf unsere Gesellschaft haben, zum Beispiel in einer US-Wahl oder bei Brexit oder bei der Bundestagswahl, dass wir da als Gesellschaft gar nicht das Recht haben, da mal tiefer reinzuschauen und Forschung zu betreiben und das zu beobachten. Aber was war deine Frage?
Nice, du könntest bald in die Politik gehen. Die Frage war, ob es Bestrebungen gibt, ob man das von außen irgendwie so beobachtet, dass man die offenen Daten halt selber herstellt. Also im Prinzip Feinstaub-Messstationen ins Facebook reinhängen.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Da kann ich den Sensor liken?
Nein, es gibt ja das System der Datenspende. Bei Open Schufa holst du dir selbst Auskunft, beim Feinstaub hältst du dir so ein Sensor ins Zimmer. Und es gab ja zum Beispiel, das ist total versandet, Buzzfeed hatte glaube ich zur Bundestagswahl dieses Ding. Man konnte seinen eigenen Facebook-Code so ein bisschen verknüpfen und dann sollte das irgendwie hoch. Ich habe da nicht mehr davon gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwie versandet ist. Aber gibt es so eine Bestrebung?
Es gab ein paralleles Projekt, das kenne ich von den Google-Suchergebnissen, um zu gucken, ob unterschiedliche Leute einfach unterschiedliche Google-Suchergebnisse bekommen, wenn sie sich über Parteien oder so etwas informieren. Da erinnere ich mich an das Ergebnis, dass dort keine großen Unterschiede waren, wie der aktuelle Stand bei Buzzfeed und Facebook ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe gesagt, vielleicht läuft das auch noch.
Würde ich aber begrüßen auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also befreit Daten, befreit Algorithmen, befreit soziale Netzwerke. Kann man das so zusammenfassen, die Sendung?
Daten für alle.
Für die Bewegung zum runterladen für alle.
Sehr schön. Dann danke ich an dieser Stelle Michael Kreil, Kira Schacht und Arne Semsrott. Ich danke dem Publikum, dass sie hier wart. Und ich danke Daniel Moe für die Redaktion dieses Chaosradios, Moe und David für den Ton. Kamera hat Kai gemacht. Die News sind geschrieben von Moe und Helena und präsentiert von Christina. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst ihr nicht überwachen. Befreit eure Daten und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.